[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
disney sing for president ordinario
y como se esperaba el presidente de
donald trump aceptó la nominación a la
presidencia por el partido republicano e
hizo un llamado a votar invocando al
miedo a la izquierda radical que según
él representa el demócrata joe bites la
medicina tradicional de los indígenas de
bolivia está en auge en las ciudades por
la crisis del comit 19 el gobierno y los
médicos aconsejan su uso para los
síntomas respiratorios leves y moderados
pero recuerdan que el coronavirus aún no
tiene cura
y el futbolista argentino lionel messi
notificó a las directivas del
fc.barcelona su intención de abandonar
el equipo
el anuncio del 6 veces ganador del
'balón de oro' generó conmoción en su
tierra natal
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal en un acto sin
precedentes el presidente de donald
trump rompió el código político y dio un
discurso desde la casa blanca para el
cierre de la convención republicana
alrededor de 1500 personas sin
mascarillas y sin cumplir con el
distanciamiento social escucharon al
mandatario durante aproximadamente una
hora
trampa acepto la candidatura
presidencial por el partido mientras en
las afueras un grupo de ciudadanos
protestaba en su contra
en su discurso trump elogió su gestión
de la pandemia y de la economía y
arremetió contra los demócratas fue un
discurso lleno de exageraciones de sus
propios logros e hizo una descripción
inexacta de joe biden y los demócratas
de hecho the new york times' revisó sus
declaraciones y encontró que varias de
ellas eran falsas o tenían la intención
de confundir el presidente evitó
referirse a un tema clave de la campaña
de este año el racismo y la violencia
policial su única referencia al tema fue
para dar respaldo a las fuerzas de
seguridad
tenemos que devolverle el poder a la
policía
nadie estará seguro en américa the
beatles mi administración siempre
apoyará a los hombres y mujeres que
apliquen la ley
y otro en romper el principio de
neutralidad fue mike pompeu quien se
convirtió en el primer secretario de
estado en ejercicio en 75 años en hablar
en una convención republicana y lo hizo
desde jerusalén
en un discurso extremista enfocado en
resaltar que bardem es según él un
aliado de los enemigos de eeuu
cuando el presidente llegó al cargo el
terrorismo radical islámico le cortaba
la cabeza a la gente y controlaba un
territorio del tamaño de gran bretaña
hoy gracias al liderazgo de donald trump
el califato del issys ha terminado
abubakar al bagdadí está muerto y
nuestros valientes soldados están de
regreso en casa
y a diferencia de la convención
demócrata la semana anterior el
encuentro republicano no contó con los
pesos pesados del partido sino más bien
fueron los familiares del mandatario los
encargados de destacar su gestión
la primera dama melania trump habló de
uno de los temas que más ha afectado en
los últimos meses a la popularidad del
presidente la gestión de la crisis de el
coronavirus en su discurso prometió que
trump luchará para encontrar la cura o
la vacuna contra el kobe 19
station la administración de mi esposo
no va a dejar de luchar hasta que exista
un tratamiento efectivo o una vacuna
disponible para todos arriba
donald no va a descansar hasta que haya
hecho todo lo que puede para cuidar a
todos los impactados por esta terrible
pandemia para estar de amics
y en esta inédita contienda a la
presidencia se ha roto la tradición de
mantener silencio mientras el partido
opositor está en su convención el
presidente de trump hizo varios actos
durante el encuentro demócrata y el
mismo día que terminaba la cita
republicana la candidata a la
vicepresidencia kamala harris arremetió
contra él
donald trump field donald trump fracaso
en el trabajo más básico e importante de
un presidente de eeuu efe el que no
logró proteger al pueblo estadounidense
simple y llanamente demostró lo que
nosotros en la profesión legal
llamaríamos un desprecio imprudente por
el bienestar del pueblo estadounidense
un desprecio imprudente reckless
disfrutar y le preguntamos a nuestra
corresponsal en washington diana
castañeda cuál es la conclusión de esta
convención republicana y que se vienen
en estos dos meses previos a la elección
estadounidense
hola qué tal una de las grandes
conclusiones de estas dos convenciones
es la polarización que se vio en los dos
partidos del lado de la convención
demócrata escuchamos expresiones como
que la democracia está en riesgo hay
racismo en los eeuu del lado republicano
se habla de socialismo de comunismo en
donde los dos partidos pues trataban de
apelar al miedo de los votantes o el
peor de los escenarios si no se elige a
cada uno de sus respectivos candidatos
otro de los temas que marcó la
diferencia en la manera en cómo se
manejó y las plataformas que mostraron
los candidatos es la pandemia del lado
demócrata hablaron de un plan de
recuperación de recuperación agresivo en
materia de economía pero también de
generar recursos suficientes para que
los hospitales y trabajadores de salud
puedan hacer frente a esta pandemia pero
también se puedan dar desarrollos para
una vacuna de lado
cano las promesas del presidente don
nacho fueron una vacuna para finales de
2020 y para 2021 volver a la normalidad
así que son dos manejos totalmente
diferentes al igual que las propuestas
en materia de generación de empleo lo
que hay que ver es si esto se traducirá
en las urnas a favor de uno o el otro
partido si los demócratas lograron
mostrar esa unidad entre los más
liberales y los más progresistas y si el
presidente de donald trump logrará que
los votantes lo elijan lo reelijan
debido a su agenda de brindar más
trabajos y que los eeuu continúe siendo
una nación grande
y es que eeuu ha vivido unas semanas
convulsas por el abuso policial hacia
los afroamericanos y este será un tema
clave en esta carrera a la casa blanca
precisamente para el aniversario número
57 del discurso i have a dream yo tengo
un sueño de martin luther king junior
las familias de las víctimas de abuso
policial y los líderes de la comunidad
afroestadounidense hablaron en el mismo
sitio en el lincoln memorial de
washington dc para pedir equidad racial
y una reforma policial
y vamos a bolivia porque la tradición se
mezcla con la necesidad cada vez más los
ciudadanos están optando por usar
hierbas medicinales para combatir
algunos síntomas del cob y 19 y tienen
el visto bueno del gobierno que fomenta
su uso pero ha advertido que no son una
solución para la pandemia veamos el
informe de nuestra corresponsal en la
paz mery vaca
en la denominada calle de las brujas de
la paz sobrevive el saber ancestral de
los indígenas de bolivia
margarita quispe es una chamán aymara
que promueve el uso de las hierbas
nativas para infecciones respiratorias y
como antisépticos naturales y
antiinflamatorios con la pandemia adapto
su negocio a la demanda causada por el
coronavirus eucalipto
neumático que previene el pulmón
el vida huida que lo preparamos balcón
que previene y lo pasa con un poco suave
no más no muy fuerte pero ya no previene
eso
ya sea por la antigua tradición de
tratamientos con plantas o por la
escasez de medicamentos en la epidemia
la población boliviana recurre con mucha
frecuencia a las hierbas medicinales el
estado fomenta ese reconocimiento pero
ha advertido que no son una solución
eficaz para el mal de la pandemia
estamos impulsando lo que es plantas
medicinales pero para infecciones
respiratorias
no podemos confirmar esto es para cobit
directamente si tenemos testimonios muy
buenos que han sido muy bien utilizados
pero no tenemos no estamos confirmando
que es para el comino los médicos
reconocen que el uso de los remedios
caseros está extendido en bolivia pero
recuerdan que el mundo sigue sin una
cura para el cob y 19 efectivamente no
hay una cura para el coronavirus ni ni
por parte farmacológica ni por parte de
piscina tradicional porque no es un
virus no tiene un tratamiento específico
las autoridades han difundido las
propiedades expectorantes y
desinflamantes de las hierbas sin
embargo han insistido en la importancia
de la higiene el uso del barbijo y el
distanciamiento social durante la
pandemia
inicio en chile la campaña para el
histórico plebiscito que pretende
reformar la constitución heredada del
régimen dictatorial de augusto pinochet
a los comicios tendrán lugar el próximo
25 de octubre y son considerados como
los más importantes en tres décadas de
democracia
la votación había sido programada
inicialmente para el 26 de abril de este
año pero fue aplazada a causa de la
pandemia del cob y 19 la consulta es uno
de los principales logros del movimiento
social de protestas que se tomó el país
a partir de octubre de 2019 y que se
extendió durante varios meses pidiendo
una reforma estructural al sistema
económico del país
el futbolista argentino lionel messi
pidió al barcelona su carta de libertad
para irse a otro club futbolístico la
decisión generó revuelo los aficionados
se agolparon a las afueras del camp nou
para rechazar la gestión del presidente
del equipo giuseppe bartoméu quien
ofreció su renuncia para garantizar que
el que es considerado como el mejor
jugador del mundo se quede le
preguntamos a nuestro corresponsal en
buenos aires- natalio cosoi cómo se
recibió el anuncio en su natal argentina
la noticia del anuncio de lionel mesi de
querer dejar el fc barcelona tuvo gran
relevancia en argentina los principales
medios lo pusieron en portada de hecho
el día martes y también el miércoles la
palabra messi fue más buscada en google
en argentina que la palabra coronavirus
que además esto se ha transformado
también aquí en argentina como muchos
otros países para los hinchas y los
fanáticos del fútbol si se quieren la
gran telenovela del año que iba a pasar
con lionel messi a donde terminará
jugando al fútbol bueno muchos especulan
con italia con francia o con inglaterra
pero aquí en su ciudad natal en rosário
los hinchas del club de fútbol mls all
boys en el que inició sus primeros pasos
y en el mes si piensan que debería ir
ahí lo que hicieron fue una marcha en
auto es una larga caravana el día jueves
pidiéndole al ídolo de rosario y del
fc.barcelona por ahora que no se vaya a
jugar a un club de europa sino que
vuelva a sus raíces a jugar en rosario
y gracias por acompañarme en esta
emisión de aquí américa recuerden que
pueden seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho de coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]
sus historias